hey guys Greg knuckles here with string
theory calm and today we have the first
installment of a new series I'm doing
for this channel theoretically I'm going
to be back on YouTube more I know that's
something I've said in the past hasn't
really stuck don't really like talking
to a camera but I'll be a big boy and
suck it up
working on finishing up the second
editions of my books the art and science
of lifting right now and that's what's
eating up most of my time so I don't
have all that much time to put out you
know kind of link the articles that are
typical for string theory just they take
a long time to write it's a lot quicker
and easier to put out videos so that's
that's what I'm going to be doing for a
while just to you know try to keep
putting out content not just drop off
the face of the earth entirely so how
this is going to work is theoretically
every day that's what I'm aiming for I'm
going to put out a video just answering
the best question that I've been asked
in the past 24 hours these ice or this
one i solicited from facebook but in the
future just comment on this video with a
question you would like answered and it
may be the one that i address in the
next video um but yeah so and for the
most part i'm going to be looking for
you know more practical questions you
know there will be some theoretical
stuff mechanistic stuff but for the most
part these are going to be videos
addressing kind of more specific
questions about how you can improve your
training so starting off with this one
the question was basically what's my
take on the overhead press military
press shoulder press whatever you call
it for bench press is does it have a
good transfer is that a good accessory
lift for the bench press
um and so
Oh in general I do think that the
overhead press is a good movement just
in its own right in general but I think
for most people it's not it's not that
good of an accessory lift for the bench
press but for some people it can be a
really good lift so kind of to address
those people first for most people the
sticking point of the bench press is in
the mid range that's where most people
tend to miss a bench press not that many
people just miss right coming off their
chest not a ton of people miss it
lockout most people miss through the mid
range however for the people who do miss
just when the bars breaking their chest
so maybe it doesn't move at all maybe it
just moves an inch or two but doesn't
you know really get to that mid-range
position that is typically going to be
limited by shoulder strength especially
when you're benching with more of a
powerlifting style bench press touching
fairly low on your chest the reason is
this essentially the distance between
the bar and your shoulder is what's
going to dictate how challenging the
lift is for your anterior deltoids so
you know essentially a bench bar path
you're going to touch here and the bar
is going to come back as you press it
out so when the bars here there's a
longer distance between where the bar is
and where your shoulder is then it
really any other point in the movement
so right there the very bottom of the
lift is going to be the most challenging
position for your shoulders and like I
said most people can get the bar moving
and stall somewhere in the mid range so
this would be for those people who you
know like everyone's going to miss right
off their chest if they take way too big
of a jump but you know let's say you got
315 completed the press put 320 325 on
barges and again moving at all
so that that would be the people that
this applies to for for those people the
shoulder press overhead press can be a
really really good accessory movement
because it is just a really good
movement for strengthening your
shoulders
if you do have that characteristic
sticking point in the bench if you do
miss at the very bottom just
strengthening your shoulders is probably
going to make a pretty big difference
for your bench so if that is where you
miss it I would recommend the overhead
press the shoulder press as an accessory
movement for your bench however most
people that's probably not where they're
going to miss you know and just simply
the harder you're training your shoulder
press that that's going to detract from
how hard you can train your bench so you
know just in terms of specificity if
you're you know if you're substituting
out maybe five sets of bench will week
for five sets of overhead press a week
you'd probably be better off doing five
more sets of bench instead now it is
certainly true that if you get a really
really really good overhead press just
simply because you'll be so strong at
pressing in general that you'll probably
also have a pretty respectable bench
from that you see that with a fair
amount of weight lifters and some strong
men most strongmen still train the bench
press but some of them don't really they
do most of their work overhead and they
can still put up respectable bench
numbers if they want to all I'm saying
here is that for most people that's
probably not the most efficient way to
improve your bench press so kind of my
own personal anecdote on this I
traditionally haven't put all that much
work into my overhead press and at one
point I was benching 435 I believe and
my max strict press was 185 which was
terrible so you know I just wanted to
get my strict press up because I was so
bad at it
so I trained it pretty hard for a while
and I didn't slack off on my bench
training it wasn't like I was doing this
at solely at the expense of benching I
was still training my bench and I put 90
pounds on my strict press I got it
up to 275 which relative to my bench
still wasn't a great overhead press
number but it was at least not like you
know he wasn't it wasn't as horrible as
it was before
and despite putting you know 90 pounds
on my overhead press when I started
focusing much harder on the bench again
when I came back to it
my bench was still 435 and it wasn't it
wasn't like a delayed transfer either I
put a really you know pretty pretty hard
dedicated training cycle into my bench
to see if the improved shoulder strength
would kind of pay off down down the line
once some of that fatigue was
ameliorated and now like six weeks later
I put I think maybe five pounds on my
bench so you know if anyone were a
candidate for improving their shoulder
press to pay big dividends for the bench
it would probably be me just because of
how bad my shoulder press was but
despite putting 90 pounds on it and
getting it up to a semi respectable
level it did absolutely nothing for my
bench press but I was never someone who
was limited by strength right off of my
chest
I could always you know get the bar
moving and then kind of missed through
that typical mid-range where most people
do so you know that's that's my own
experience with attempting to use the
overhead press to improve my bench
so I think kind of playing the long game
I think that if you have the type of
acromion process that that allows you to
tolerate overhead movements well that's
another video topic for another day but
essentially your chromium process of
your scapula kind of the roof of your
shoulder joint some people just have
more room in that joint than others and
so most people can overhead press fine
without issue other people that don't
have quite as much space in that joint
pretty much anything overhead is going
to be problematic or at least increase
their impingement risk but for most
people who can tolerate overhead
movements fine I do think that the
shoulder press is a good thing just to
have kind of in your base programming so
if you're a competitor and you're
offseason programming if you're you know
if you're just a bro just trying to live
to get jacked a good thing to keep in
your programming because it's a pressing
movement where your scapula aren't
pinned and in general that's probably
going to be better just for you know
shoulder health resilience in the long
run so similar movements would be like a
band resisted push-ups weighted dips etc
so I do think that it's a very good
movement in its own right
for that reason just helping you get
strong at pressing in general while also
you know maybe being a little bit better
for shoulder health for most people than
the bench press because your scapula
aren't pinned in that immobile position
but like I said for if you're if you're
looking for a movement specifically to
improve your bench press it's probably
not going to be the best accessory
movement for most people especially
because it it's also a pretty taxing
movement and will probably take away
from how hard you can train your bench
press however if you do miss just at the
very start of the press it's a great
movement and it's probably something
that if you add it to your training will
help your bench press so that was the
first addition I'll come up with a
snappy name for these videos at some
point not good at that but until next
time if you have a question just ask it
in the comments below or if you're
watching this on Facebook just that same
thing comment below and if I like your
question I will answer it in the next
video alright see you guys then